how's it going man nice today we got to
play a new horror game called Walden and
the werewolf
here we go I can choose game or book for
the [ __ ] would choose book what happens
matches book ah oh you're welcome
what the [ __ ] just happened don't choose
book okay whatever you do don't choose
book ha ha
let's choose game
love the music it's like a sneaky little
Shetty's playing in the background start
was an upon a time
anywhere was for yes raven town
remaining piece paper planted and gather
their seats with
nearby lived a hunter called Walton he
had a really ugly beard he was known as
the black sheep of the region a lowly
sad B and they can't clench their guns
of course nothing can be expected from a
personal loss under midlife a few years
ago Walla was attacked by three most
dangerous assassin not that hand but
it's being repelled everything in the
Hunter was searching for the RAM that
appeared but why isn't he holding the
gun where it man the Bandit fired after
being hit by the first shot woman
managed to draw his gun and fire three a
great shot down the devil's three a good
shot on the table girl rumors say that
the wallet was found in such big
for a flatte that is impossible
that it would be possible enemy
somehow girl somehow girl he still was
from that day on Walden locked himself
few years pass he still can't know how
to hold [ __ ] while they decided to leave
his house while the Sun did he have a
lamp on his head holy [ __ ] that's
awesome
oddly the blue sky started rocking in an
expect ball a
Walden calmly lights his loyal Antonin
returned town best story ever told them
the best way ever I love it holy [ __ ] I
really do trust my lantern I'm holding
it like ha ha ha ha laughs I got belly
got a me maybe all right well I suppose
we have to go in here
ha Can I grab it holy [ __ ] this is the
best game ever
ha get away from me your [ __ ] chest
what the [ __ ] are you know 1 ba let's go
upstairs shall be what are you doing
here make me angry why is it dark ha ha
now pets not good enough I already
figured out thank you very much hey pet
I love you
hey stop just shut up what am i doing am
i looking for something table flip
what's going on out there it's kind of
crew spooky Oh some ammo
nice ok whoa what the what ok well I got
some loot I thought it was gonna shut it
I'm stuck
ok there we go alright it despite it
looks like everything is rubbed in oil I
kind of whoa I don't like it okay Babs
what do I know any what you make are you
sure I swear
why would I lie to your parents I love
you you know that
alright fine goddammit
I'm ready to Kris are to reload okay
holy [ __ ] that's loud god damn it
I guess we're whoa okay so we're going
outside to wear this magical flying
arrow I guess I have to go here huh
object them cross the bridge what hello
Oh
I don't like this hello
I'm not tapping this is not my happy
face accepted by all [ __ ]
for that for that for that for that I'm
a gun don't come near me don't come near
me I will shoot you in the ass
only if you back up in front of me I'll
do it okay we're fine it's all good in
the hood
my arm is still very handsome Oh what's
happening what happened
Oh cutscene well that didn't feel fair
for yeas but this was about to change
this nipples were now wet the sprit
screams echoed through the mountains
sounds of destructions and to dance man
Oh destruction is coming
welcome to rubbing town huh this place
used to be a nice place
until it got awful fire animation what
the [ __ ] it's not a lantern holy [ __ ]
this place is filled with ashes now
makes me angry oh okay I have a map and
the map is telling me to go here is that
it hello hello oh it works holy [ __ ]
you [ __ ] battle get away not god damn
it who put you up what's going on here
don't make me kill you
oh shut shut check sorry I didn't mean
to shoot how do I take you up hey you
are my deke floating in front of my face
and now you go inside my pants no I like
it what what is that I like it's an arm
Hey
I don't need my own hands I have another
hand that's also chair flip yeah that's
right savage care to take off
damn that's down how do I open I can't
go out oh [ __ ]
hello I'm sorry you can have your
handbag
what just kidding what do we go now over
there okay
anyone in here hello hat stop touching
the house hand what are you doing
and what is my hat you don't have to
touch everything I got damn your
perverted a little bit well what is this
oh don't touch that hat you want to
stroke it well that's okay that's a nice
doggie
that's a very nice doggie oh I like that
could be a friend for you had I had come
down okay you don't need friends oh it's
a cow oh that's a nice cow you got
had we shall move on okay here we go
all right add and you are coming
awkwardly from my penis region whoa what
is going on here I have a hand don't
come near me
whoa whoa whoa what was that you [ __ ]
barrel what is happening do something
really bad happened
we unlocked that door [ __ ] I don't like
this
another key oh oh what the [ __ ] is going
on
shut up Han did you do it
what hello take the key Jose I won't see
why did you do it
oh are you touching me now and I like it
Oh all right where did we go now
out get the [ __ ] away from me uhh
here yeah yeah it's here those houses on
fire that's not good I don't know how
you unlock a barn door but [ __ ] [ __ ] me
all right what do we got more dead
people nice leg did it Directorate just
walk in and work sorry hand leg is
clearly superior get away from me that's
right laughs like we need to go in here
move them perfect thank you like don't
worry about pets I'm a leg you are damn
right about that you are the sexiest
like I've ever seen
I need wet I need wet clothes really
okay how do I get wet clothes oh oh I
feel so good I thought my my clothes
were still wet from from the pond or l44
falling from the bridge sure whatever
alright so now we are wet and we can go
near the flames hello flames
how are you Oh what the [ __ ] oh that
must have been hands I must've been
hands before he died hey there sir
like you're blocking you're blocking me
well I just came why would you do that
you black son of a [ __ ] oh wait that
not that don't okay goddamnit leg what
the [ __ ] uh did I miss something okay
like like stop humping the wall god damn
it
alright head huh what what no don't like
this don't like this don't like that uh
okay
we got a key let's keep going leave this
town okay cool I like that I like that
it looks like I'm kicking the air while
I'm walking ha ha ha ha ha come at me
[ __ ] is that what you cut a salary
it was amazing this is best [ __ ] ever
this is how are we walking Sweden watch
and learn
oh god it's gonna load now probably I
hope we don't lose mr. leg
Lisa leg is like the best god no I lost
my grip on him alright still got it
Walden was completely tormented and
couldn't explain what had happened in
his village whoa who would be the
mysterious being that left him a letter
containing a Talaash thousands of
question passed through his mind but he
knew one thing this mission is the only
way to unravel all the missed [ __ ] I try
seven moon for it I don't like the sound
of that alright objective make a bonfire
or I can do that [ __ ] I got it
if I had if I had you know legs are
extremely flammable if I had a hammer I
could just well that was easy
uh two out of five why do I need five
two is fine God whoa
all right what do we do now what I swear
to god I see [ __ ] Oh God Oh God
is this evil dead oh oh oh oh wow I
can't do higher I actually really like
this game it's it's so it's it's kind of
like a horror movie
whoa don't like this game big on spawn
of Satan what the [ __ ] is that what is
that it sound like a dick it sounds like
a dick is chasing me
whoa [ __ ] rania piece of crap what is
your problem
well [ __ ] I can't go there yet
what well girls that's not fair that's
not fair man that sound cool I gonna
have to end this episode here but I hope
you guys enjoyed this is only an alpha
version of like had the trees dangling
look at this [ __ ] as you can tell it's
only an alpha version of the M it is so
fun I actually enjoyed it I'm surprised
they like if you enjoyed as well it's a
sky Cobra today I'll see Bruce in the
next one say awesome love you regardless
for paralyzer after [ __ ] that what is
wrong with me Miley before and then
after